[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans 16 autres cas dit bonjour jimmy et
bonjour josette manin dont je me suis
qu'un juge bonjour à tous les auditeurs
de martinique 1ère député apparenté
socialiste de la première
circonscription de martinique celle
qu'on a l'habitude de nommer comme celle
du centre atlantique centre atlantique
c'est bien cela voilà et puis vous être
également tout le rap les membres du
parti bâtir le pays martinique qui a été
créée par pierre samot exact ancien
maire maire honoraire du lamentin
josette matin josette manin excusez moi
qu'elle a été ou quels ont été les
champs prioritaires de vos récentes
actions et interventions à l'assemblée
nationale mais écoutez monsieur car il
sait difficile aujourd'hui de parler de
chant priorité dans la mesure où nous
les parlementaires ultramarins on a du
mal aujourd'hui à rejoindre nous fait
l'assemblée par l'assemblée nationale ou
le sénat pour mes collègues du sénat
parce que bon on a quand même des
obligations de tests de vaccins et
caetera et donc c'est tout à fait
compliqué il faut dire aussi que nous
travaillons plutôt en visioconférence
avec nous nos commissions donc avec nos
collègues de commissions et je dirais
que le la seul le seul point d'attaché
qu'on pourrait avoir aujourd'hui c'est
quand on intervient donc en question
gouvernement donc nous avons
l'obligation d'être en séance d'être en
présentiel
mais aujourd'hui nous travaillons sert
plus jeune dit chez nous que ce soit
dans les bureaux ou chez nous en maison
donc c'est vrai que dernièrement il ya
eu beaucoup de textes qui sont
intervenus mais je dis que même des
petits textes
alors cette semaine par exemple à
l'assemblée nationale c'est la semaine
de mon groupe le groupe socialiste donc
pointé revenir sur différents sujets
tous les sujets qu'ils ont choisi pour
mener à bien
nous lutterons marin on a je dirais
qu'on n'intervient peut sur ces sujets
et j'ai presque envie de vous dire des
sujets qui l'intéressent peut-être pas
les gens de l'assemblée nationale
cependant dans la semaine qui arrive
nous avons nous allons intervenir sur le
le projet de loi climat sur lequel
justement je vais porter un certain
nombre d'amendements j'ai une dizaine
d'amendements a porté sur eux sur ce
texte notamment sur les problématiques
de bord de mer chez nous de 50 pas
géométriques et c'est donc ce sont des
sujets quand même qui nous intéresse ce
qui intéresse notre territoire et sur
lequel je veux faire entendre quand même
la voix la voix de notre territoire
martinique
voilà alors l'université en revanche
vous étiez intervenus ces derniers mois
ces dernières années vous êtes même
auteur avec une autre députée d'un
rapport parlementaire sur la situation
de l'université des antilles et vous
préconisiez un certain nombre de
dispositions à prendre pour améliorer la
situation
un an après ce la remise de ce rapport
parlementaire pas grand chose n'a changé
sinon peut-être en pire puisqu'il ya une
grève qui est là et pas seulement une
grève parce que j'ai entendue depuis du
jour donc largement le témoignage d'une
enseignante et france au travail voilà
et nous avions relaté justement dans
notre rapport et dans d'autres rapports
qui avait précédé le nôtre les
souffrances justement de ce personnel de
l'université
je dirais pas le personnel de
l'université mme adam fait du pôle
martinique mais d'une du pôle et c'est
vrai qu'il ya une souffrance et là elle
parle de harcèlement et c'est vrai que
peut-être on a on n'a pas voulu utiliser
le mot parce que c'est un mot qui est
très fort mais là elle l'a dit et on a
vu des gens qui se sont mises à pleurer
devant nous lorsqu'ils sont venus en
audition on a vu des professeurs qui
tend longue maladie qui n'ont pas pu
intervenir mais qui sont venus après
nous dire effectivement ce qu'ils
vivaient sur cet univers sur ce pôle
universitaire sur l'ensemble des pôles
et c'est vrai que dans le rapport nous
avions fait des préconisations des
préconisations sur justement cet aspect
souffrance qui vous avait valu quand
même une volée de bois vert comme on dit
de la part de certains persos monsieur
dont le réputé servat olivier servent à
votre on va dire que ce sont des aléas
du métier on va dit voilà c'est les
inconvénients du métier j'ai vécu
justement ces volets de boîtes de bois
vert
j'ai tenu bon j'ai pas voulu justement
une mission a été confiée je suis allé
jusqu'au bout
josette manin c'est quand même une
affaire qui vous préoccupent qui
continue de vous préoccuper de ce je
pense même que cela vous tient peut-être
un peu à coeur parce que dans une
question écrite toute récente du 9 mars
dernier
oui vous interveniez à nouveau la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
absolument sur le mouv et une
contestation des enseignants des
étudiants des personnels administratifs
des pôles martinique et guadeloupe vous
le disiez mouvements dus à des
problématiques structurelles dans la
gestion de l'université des souffrances
au travail voilà on y revient des
dérives organisationnelles dans la
gouvernance de cette institution vous
rappeliez justement que dans le rapport
parlementaire
il y avait des recommandations claires
pour apaiser le débat sur la répartition
des moyens entre les pôles régionaux
clarifier les textes achever les travaux
en cours via des contrats d'objectifs et
de moyens et vous dites que depuis la
remise de ce rapport aucune suite n'a
été donnée sur les éventuels
appréciation mise en oeuvre de ces
propositions
vous avez réservé votre voix n'est pas
entre vous avez vraiment tout dit vous
avez tout dit alors mais nous maintenons
nos voix ne sont pas entendus a pas que
la voix de joseph manès il ya ya ya
quand même la collègue qui était à côté
de moi dans dans dans la proposition de
préconisations de respect
daniel denis guérin donc qu'ils aient
une collègue de la majorité qui relance
régulièrement donc le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur et je m'apprête
justement la semaine prochaine à
intervenir aux questions au gouvernement
pour à nouveau interpellé la ministre
sur justement la non réponse à ses
préconisations la non-réponse un
courrier que je que je lui fais que vous
avez rappelé la date le 9 mars lieu lors
du déclenchement de la grève sur les
différents pôles et j'espère que cette
fois ci j'aurai une réponse mais en fait
l'ensemble des parlementaires auront
donc une réponse puisqu'il va falloir
effectivement le trm une décision parce
que la réalité je le 6 on apprend mais
je ne sais pas si j -lm ans elle prendra
une décision vous savez une question
gouvernement ces deux minutes il a mis
la mini c'est là aussi deux minutes peut
être effectivement à ce moment là elle
va trouver le moyen de répondre au
courrier aux différentes interpellations
je l'espère en tout cas parce que notre
université en a besoin oui alors il ya
urgence que le gouvernement joue
peut-être et on terminera sur ce
chapitre parce qu'il faut qu'on
10 quelques mots du dossier le
chlordécone de la chlordécone mais
peut-être que le gouvernement joue la
montre parce qu'on a appris que bon ça
reste à vérifier mais que le mandat du
président l'université courait jusqu'au
mois d'août la prochain donc ouais mais
c'est un jour elle encore non mais c'est
un mandat qui est justement vient et ça
c'était c'était prévu et donc
normalement c'est bien la raison les
raisons pour lesquelles il ya tout ce
branle bas de combat donc au niveau de
la gouvernance pour je ne veux pas
effectivement celle qui va faire de la
délation mais pour justement qu'il y ait
un remplacement de son président par un
autre président de venant de la
guadeloupe c'est ce qui est en train de
se mettre en place c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a décidé d'écarter la
martinique de la gouvernance de
l'université
il a été dit justement que depuis de
longues années la martinique a eu la
présidence de l'université par les
différents présidents que nous avons
eues et qu' il n'est plus question que
ce soit la martinique qu'il est il faut
que les choses soient faites de façon à
ce que la guadeloupe est encore une
présidente d'université
donc voila un petit peu les manoeuvres
qui sont qui sont en ce moment en cours
et donc j'espère effectivement que la
ministre va mettre un peu du sien c'est
dans ses décisions ce serait dommage que
ça se résume à une concurrence ou une
espèce de vengeance entre oui absolument
d'autant que si les choses étaient
équitables entre les deux entre les
différents administrateurs d'université
je pense qu'il repas et problème mais le
problème c'est que il ya un manque
d'équité entre justement les décisions
qui sont prises qui sont prises
uniquement par la partie guadeloupéen
dans la question écrite vous mettiez en
conclusion que ce que selon vous il est
à noter qu'aucun problème relationnel
n'existe entre les étudiants et les
personnels enseignants ainsi
qu'administratif des deux pôles et qu'
il y a la volonté de garder une unité au
sein de l'université
absolument et je précise effectivement
qu' il n'y a pas de volonté de scission
dans cette université antilles ni par
les métaux les professeurs ni parler les
étudiants alors en septembre 2020
vous avez posé une question orale au
ministre d outre-mer concernant cette
fois la chlordécone les suit les
solutions qu'il faut qu'il faut à
apporter à l usage de ce pesticide de ce
polluant chez nous donc vous rappeliez
qu'une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire a établi les réseaux des
responsabilités en matière d'utilisation
de ce poison vous utiliser ce terme vous
aussi josette manin
et puis vous dit quand vous adressiez à
sébastien lecornu nous attendons
toujours les concrétisations des
préconisations contenues là encore dans
le rapport la commission d' enquête
parlementaire dont faisait partie
notamment serge letchimy de la
martinique et justine bénin de la grêle
de la guadeloupe c'est l'humain nous
attendons toujours les concrétisation
des mesures malgré des promesses faites
le 27 septembre 2018 par le président de
la république
voilà alors et alors sébastien lecornu a
dit oui on reconnaît aujourd'hui il faut
accélérer
vous avez raison de le rappeler alors il
ya des plan chlordécone 4 oui alors bien
évidemment je pense qu'il avait entendu
il avait en tête
ce fameux plan chlordécone 4 qui
apportait je dirais quelques éclairages
1dans dans la démarche de demande de
réparation j'ai envie d'y puisque c'est
ce que nous demandons une réparation
pour l'empoisonnement que nous avons vu
que notre population effectivement à a
payé très cher je rappelle que nous
avons énormément de personnes qui sont
décédées du fait de cette molécule de
chlordécone nous avons beaucoup de
malades
on a vu aujourd'hui des collectifs se
former justement pour moutier au créneau
demander réparation je me se manifester
dans en fin de semaine nous avons donc
un collectif encore qu'il va fait une
grande manifestation sur le territoire
du lamentin à bausch est donc je crois
que tous les moyens sont bons pour
rappeler au président de la république
sa promesse qu'il a faite au mont rouge
et nous y tenons et je crois que la
population et 20 dans le temps dans le
sang ce sens il ya une directrice de
projet pour la mise en oeuvre du plan du
plan chlordécone 4 pour la guadeloupe et
la martinique
elle est basée au ministère de
l'outre-mer à paris mais elle viendra de
temps en temps en guadeloupe et en
martinique
vous comptez prendre sont attachés une
martiniquaise 1 c'est à dire oui
bon c'est pas parce qu elle une
martiniquaise non je dire effectivement
c'était d'ailleurs une promesse qu'avait
fait je crois que là cette promesse a
été tenue
on l'a on l'a vu très décemment
justement lors du plan chlordécone 4
malheureusement j'ai pas pu être en
préfecture est-ce que c'est pas évident
aujourd'hui de se rendre sur dans les
administrations donc nous sommes
toujours en visio et je crois que c'est
une très bonne chose mais je pense qu'il
faut qu'elle prenne la mesure de la
tâche qui l'attend et de ce que nous
allons effectivement demandé parce que
ce n'est pas le fait de nous mais
quelques aller la rencontre et vous
demanderez urbaine
évidemment nous allons nous allons
certainement demander audience de toute
façon de façon à savoir quelle est sa
feuille de route
comment elles pensent travailler de
concert avec le territoire avec les
territoires
ce que je rappelle que c'est la
guadeloupe et si la martinique qui sont
dans cette démarche de demande de
réparation donc oui on va certainement
on va demander à la rencontrer mais
c'est vrai que ce n'est pas évident
aujourd'hui de rencontrer des
personnalités
je vous donne juste un exemple j'ai
demandé j'ai travaillé avec trois
collègues il ya deux ans sur justement
un rapport que nous avons présenté à la
délégation outre-mer souligner les
inégalités et donc ça fait déjà des
studios des mois et des mois qu'on
attend justement que la première mini
justement qui étaient là qu'elle nous
reçoivent elle ne l'a pas fait
aujourd'hui madame mori nous accepte
effectivement de nous recevra je
m'attendais justement à être à son
ministère de façon à échanger avec mes
deux collègues mais elle nous donne
rendez-vous en visio c'est très
difficile de travailler avec avec ces
gens là donc c'est vrai qu'on va
certainement demande une rencontre mais
je ne sais pas si ce sera ce sera une
rencontre en présentiel aller en une
minute
on va conclure pour les élections avec
les élections à la collectivité
territoriale de martinique josette manin
le week-end dernier serge letchimy a
annoncé être candidat à la candidature
il faudra que ce soit validé par les
instances du ppm mais aussi des partis
qui font partie de la nouvelle de
l'addition et l'addition
serge letchimy à tout votre soutien ses
membres cette campagne c'est lui moi
mais je vous signale m
je vous signale que j'étais présente à
cette grande manifestation dimanche
dernier
moi j'étais là avec pias amour avec le
maire du lamentin l'ensemble de jeudi
que des forces se lamente chinoises
étaient présentes notamment ceux de
bâtir le pays martinique puisque nous
sommes depuis de longues années membre
de cette alliance et je crois savoir
mais je ne me trompe pas puisque je suis
à des lignes de bâtir régulièrement que
nous sommes encore dans la démarche avec
serge letchimy si éventuellement serge
letchimy valide sa candidature c'est un
retour c'est pas une candidature
nouvelles n'ont pas nuire le remettre
aux affaires il avait été président de
la région et au changement mais écoutez
nous avons nous avons des hommes et des
femmes de valeur je ne vois pas pourquoi
on va nous annoncer
sauf à dire qu'il y en a d'autres qui
sollicité que la population va faire un
choix je crois bien évidemment qui sera
soit le ch
un choix logique pardon dans une
démarche de faire avancer la martinique
merci josette manin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions bonne journée c'est moi
qui vous remercie bonne journée à tous
[Musique]